so comic-con's almost over it is and I'm
really sad that's sad I mean we've had
some good times some especially great
times we've met a lot of friends we can
afford to really solid memories totally
in business pleasure Arlene lon all
together coming together get out Terry
honey I little misty-eyed I mean I
really like but walking the floor
there's a lot of movies I'm excited to
see so that's going to be with your
ground movie with you the meatballs
movie cloudy with a chance of meatballs
or the meatballs I refer to it as the
meatballs balls will be okay which is
confusing especially since there was a
movie called me my blue star Bill Murray
yes it was a classic it was a rocky
watch vest so no 3d cloudy with a chance
of meatballs yeah we talked to those
guys super excited about the movie if I
think it's going to be really really
strange i think it's going to be kind of
like an acid trip meets 3d beeps and
easy to Notre dos be diff overdose but i
think it's going to be a pretty fun
movie and really out there really weird
very like life of brian sort of
accommodating any I'm super stoked about
it no what are you more sporting man i'm
so excited about district nine then yeah
that's really that's it that's a serious
movie this reader dark yes yeah it's
about Elliot Park I is about I can't
take my kids to the street don't have
kids not yeah but by the time it comes
out right maybe maybe maybe it's
actually coming out at the 40th so one
month august that's soon that's Gracie
are you all ready kids do then I don't
know none that I know about best part
about comic-con to me is the fact that
it's kind of an anything-goes
environment where I see these costumes
at all sort of like levels of the
spectrum right there's two who were
wearing like basically a garbage bag
with an A on it and I'm Captain America
then they got and they're not even come
no no they're just really honored but
basically yet and some of the people
have like full-on Nazi uniforms where
you actually think they're actually
going to know God but exciting is that
you meet people that are wearing
costumes that you have no idea what they
are right in there are people who are
maybe making movies about being covered
by the mainstream press we met a
spaceman dresses spaceman this guy was
named George Willis here's passing out
chewing gum chewing gum promoting his
movie Hollywood UFO it's a documentary
about people from Los Angeles who claim
to have been abducted by aliens whatever
do you think this is crazy to make sure
there's no razor blades in this let's
really see this let's try to kids do not
try this present no don't take candy
from strangers